هل تعتقد أن الكثير من دول العالم
أصبحت غير متأثرة بالمشاهد خارج غزة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسكان المدنيين؟ أعداد
القتلى والجرحى المذهلة تتسبب في
الجوع والمعاناة. هل تعتقد أن
حجم كل ذلك
مفهوم تمامًا خارج القطاع؟  أعني أن
الفلسطينيين أصبحوا دهومًا، وآمل ألا يحدث ذلك، وآمل
أن يفهم الناس أن هؤلاء
هم الأشخاص، هؤلاء مدنيون، أطفال،
نساء، للأسف يفقدون
كرامتهم في الوقت الفعلي، نحن نرى
ذلك يحدث، نحن نرى
الناس يبكون من أجل الطعام يبكون  خارجًا
للحصول على الماء، إنهم يائسون،
وآمل ألا يصبح العالم مخدرًا
بسبب ذلك لأنه لا يزال يحدث كل
يوم، رأيت عائلة لديها
أم طفلة صغيرة وطفلة حافية القدمين تجري حافي القدمين
على الطريق تحت النار تحاول
الهروب  آمل ألا نصاب بالخدر تجاه ما
نحتاجه، ولهذا السبب نحتاج إلى
وقف إطلاق النار، نحتاج إلى فهم
مستوى المعاناة الإنسانية وجعلها
تتوقف خارج النافذة بجواري،
هناك الآلاف من الأشخاص الذين يعيشون في
ملاجئ مؤقتة
هنا.  في رافا، كل رصيف
مغطى بالملاجئ، أصبحت المزيد والمزيد من
الأراضي غير آمنة والناس
في حالة تنقل مستمر بما في ذلك
زملائي الذين اضطروا إلى التحرك
ثلاث مرات وأربع وخمس مرات آه لمواصلة
البحث عن الأمان، والجو يزداد برودة،
ويصبح المطر ممطرًا هنا  والعديد من
الأشخاص، بما في ذلك الأشخاص الذين
يبعدون عني 50 مترًا، ينامون تحت
البلاستيك